[INTRO MUSIC]
BRIAN MOROZ: Good afternoon--
or morning, everyone.
Welcome to the third in our
Google Creative Sandbox
Gallery Hangout series.
Today, we're going to be talking
about some really
astounding uses of DoubleClick
technology.
And to kick it off this
afternoon here in New York,
I'm actually going to hand it
over to my colleague, Ryan,
out on the West Coast, who
works with DoubleClick.
He's going to talk a little
bit about the platform.
We're going to run a quick video
that gives you some idea
of what can be done with it.
And then we're going to be
speaking with Grow and with
Spinnaker about their fantastic
uses of this
technology.
Ryan?
RYAN TETUAN: Cool,
just in time.
Sorry, guys.
I had a quick venue switch.
So everyone, obviously, on the
Hangout here is familiar with
DoubleClick Rich Media, right?
Because the creative agencies
here leverage the tool.
Just to give you some
background,
I'm right Ryan Tetuan.
I work on, obviously, the
DoubleClick end of Google.
My team works with creative
agencies across the US, right?
So we really want you guys to
understand the capabilities of
DoubleClick Rich Media and,
overall, the DoubleClick
platform as a whole.
So I think we think have
a video cued up.
We're going to give you guys a
quick 90-second sizzle of what
DoubleClick Rich Media
is all about.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RYAN TETUAN: Cool.
Are we back on?
BRIAN MOROZ: Back on.
RYAN TETUAN: Awesome.
So that, obviously, was a number
of Rich Media examples
we just ran through.
I think that video highlights
some of the big, in your face,
take over Rich Media units
that you might see
browsing the web.
Working, specifically, I'm
based in Los Angeles.
And a lot of the entertainment
clients here in LA, the
Hollywood studios, have the
budgets and have the luxury of
media placements, like a YouTube
masthead, to be able
to create these crazy page
takeovers, right?
And I think at the end, at the
second half of this, you'll
see what the Spinnaker team did
taking a James Bond film
and creating a really engaging
YouTube masthead with that.
But not all advertisers are
brands and have the luxury of
a canvas that size on the media
plane that includes,
lets say, a media place
for a masthead.
So let's say you're just given
a 300x250, and you have a CPG
[? grant ?]
to execute with.
At that point, you've got to
start figuring out the best
way to get users to engage with
the Rich Media unit when
you don't have that type
of a placement.
And I think what Drew and the
Grow team did, taking a brand
like Alka-Seltzer was really
taking the power of
DoubleClick's technology
platform and all the data
signals that we can tap into
and really creating a
relevant, engaging,
rich experience.
And I think with that, I'll
pass it over to Brian and
Drew, and we'll sort of walk
through that first example.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
So the beauty of having Ryan on
the call here is twofold.
One, the agencies that are on
the call today and going to be
talking about their work, you're
welcome to grill him,
yell at him, anything you like
as far as the product goes.
Demand things.
And for those of you that are
watching live, both with the
agencies that have done this
incredible work as well as
having Ryan here, please feel
free to pop in on our
moderator tool-- which we'll
be putting the link up
throughout the course
of the Hangout--
and ask any questions you'd
like of the folks in the
agency, Ryan.
It's a great place to get
your questions answered.
So with that, Drew, are
you on the line there?
DREW UNGVARSKY: I'm
here, yeah.
BRIAN MOROZ: Excellent.
Firstly Drew, do you want to
introduce yourself, your
position within the company,
and talk a little
bit about the work?
And then we'll go ahead
and run the video.
DREW UNGVARSKY: Cool.
I'm Drew Ungvarsky, the owner
and creative director at Grow.
We're a digital agency and
production studio working both
directly with brands and with
the advertising agencies as a
production shop.
We partnered with Google on
Project Re:Brief last year.
And Alka-Seltzer is one of
four brands where we,
essentially, tried to re-imagine
classic advertising
as if it was done today.
And if it was done today, what
are the tools that you could
have used to do that in
a much more engaging
and relevant way?
BRIAN MOROZ: So let's go ahead
and run a video of the work,
and then we'll jump back in.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I can't believe I ate
that whole thing.
-In Project Re:Brief, we
re-imagined Alka-Seltzer's
iconic "I can't believe I ate
whole thing" by bringing back
the original ad's character,
Ralph, through personalized
videos and immersive experiences
about the day
Ralph ate the whole thing.
Each experience is customized
to its viewer as story
elements change with cues such
as location, time, weather,
and the context of website,
making Ralph more relevant
than ever before.
The ad experience begins with a
classic opening montage, in
which scenes and elements are
customized to make it relevant
to the viewer's environment.
For example, users in New York
would see Ralph driving
through Times Square, while
those viewing it in Chicago
would find familiar elements
of the Windy City.
As the viewer's weather changes,
so does the weather
in the story.
Story elements can also change
based on the user's interests.
So when Ralph receives a package
from his postman
during the afternoon episode,
contents of his package adjust
accordingly.
-It's a mail-order chess set.
-When the ad is placed on
YouTube, Ralph's TV plays the
same video, and he reacts based
on the video's category.
Each episode gives the users
an option to influence the
story directly by interacting
with Ralph.
When Ralph and Fred disagree
about the radio station, a
viewer can step in to help
pick a song, leading to a
variety of outcomes.
-[INAUDIBLE].
-They can even call the lead
character and interact with
him during the dinner episode.
Each story leads up to Ralph
eating the whole thing.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN MOROZ: OK, so that is a
very complicated piece of
creative with a lot
of moving pieces.
So we'll get into the technology
and how you
actually put it together
in just a moment.
But just to kick off the
conversation, let's talk about
the idea process first.
So you've got this square of
real estate and the things
that you can do within it.
What is the idea generation
process like
for you guys at Grow?
How did you approach
this project?
How did you come up with all
of these different moving
pieces in the way that they
all came together?
DREW UNGVARSKY: Sure, yeah.
Well, keep in mind, we kind of
had the luxury of this being a
twofold process.
Yes, one, we were
doing this ad.
We're re-imagining this ad.
We're also creating an
experiment about the process.
So in a lot of ways, we
were analyzing what
it is we were doing.
How do you actually
create this stuff?
How could we get in a room with
legends of advertising
and teach them to do
the same thing?
So the process, for us was
understand all of the tools in
the toolbox.
Try to get some understanding
of what are
the different platforms.
Why is it a relevant tool?
Why is it not just,
as it's often
treated, a print ad re-sized?
But that we can do the things
that the Google platform
allows us to do--
serving ads to people.
When you say at the right time
and the right place for the
right person, what
does that mean?
And how can that be a really
effective tool not just for
sales and engagement but even
for entertainment, in the case
of Alka-Seltzer?
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
So basically, just rethinking
the entire concept of what
that ad unit could be.
So you mentioned what are all
the tools in the toolbox.
And I think that's something
that comes up with agencies
and with clients, and even
sometimes here, internally, at
Google, there's just so much
you can play with.
How did you guys, A, figure out
what are all the tools?
How did you just stockpile
all that list?
And then how did you select
amongst the things that you
had to say, these are the six
things we want to play with?
DREW UNGVARSKY: Sure.
To be honest, I'd say early on
in the process, a lot of the
stuff wasn't very
well documented.
So we had a tough time
getting through it.
Since then, we know, even
through the end of the
campaign in some stuff that
we're doing now, lots of the
tools, specifically how the GDN
works, how a YouTube buy
works and what features are
available to you, some of the
different tools, certainly
across platforms, are very
well documented and even nicely
packaged into the right
pages and videos and so forth
to learn those things.
In our case, we wanted to,
again, survey those
technologies.
We were looking for ways we
could use them in places that
they hadn't yet been used.
And we identified a list of
about 20 things that we
thought, from a creative and
technology standpoint, would
be really amazing if
we could highlight.
And then, as we looked at each
brand, Alka-Seltzer in
particular, we would say, OK,
what is that brief all about?
If that brief is all about, in
the case of Alka-Seltzer, was
relevancy, it was everyone could
relate to Ralph sitting
on the side of his bed.
And so, what are the tools that
are available to us that
really allow us to showcase
relevancy?
And so you could look at that
across other brands like Coke,
Buy the World a Coke, where you
say, well, that's a social
experiment.
That's a social brand.
Let's look at social
tools and so forth.
So picking the tools
based on that.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
So let me ask you a question.
Did you pick out the
technologies you guys thought
were relevant and then develop
the idea around that
technology, which sounds like
maybe that's what you did?
But I maybe am misreading
that.
Or did you say, these are the
stories we want to tell, and
now I need to find the correct
technology that will actually
make this story happen?
What was the chicken, and
what was the egg?
DREW UNGVARSKY: So we had the
chicken and the egg and, I
think, the farmer all at the
table at the same time.
The goal was look at
it from all angles.
Look at it very much from
a creativity standpoint.
Look at it from the
original brief.
Look at it as, how could we
re-imagine that brief?
And again, if you've got a room
full of people who are
creating ideas, make sure that
they know what tools are in
their toolbox.
And so the part of the process
I just described was, really,
just about toolbox building.
When we actually went and
started concepting, we really
looked at things creatively.
We looked at what were the
stories we wanted to tell.
And then we immediately knew
what types of tools we had
available to us to do
that sort of thing.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And so you mentioned having all
the people in the room,
which leads me to my
next question.
Who worked on the project?
What kind of roles?
How big was the team?
Can you give us a sense of just
who all was involved and
what they did?
DREW UNGVARSKY: Sure.
The project is an experiment
from Google, and we
essentially engaged Grow
and another agency
called Johannes Leonardo.
Grow was the lead
digital agency.
Johannes Leonardo was the
lead creative agency.
And then we worked with the
original creative or art
directors on the project to
bring them into the room.
In a lot of ways it sort of
became a microcosm of what is
going on right now in the
industry, that you have
agencies, that you have
production partners, that you
have brands.
You try to figure out when
you get them in the room.
And there's an increasing trend
towards getting everyone
in the room at the same time.
And that was certainly the
model that we had.
Everyone was in the room.
And so to answer your question,
we had a number of
creatives, whether those would
be traditional creatives, art
directors, copywriters, people
you might classify as creative
technologists, and onto full-on
developers who just
understood some of
the technologies.
And critical to the whole
process was the idea of a
visionary creative director
who could guide us through
what the thinking was behind
that specific insight and how
we could bring that
to life today.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And that actually, I think,
leads to an interesting
question, because I think
commonly, when you have people
that really get the technology,
get what can be
done with it, and come up with
the creative ideas, if the
client or if other folks in the
agency, depending on your
situation, aren't that
comfortable with the
technology, it can be a little
bit of a hurdle to try to get
them to understand it, back it,
and get excited about it.
So how did you go about that?
Did you have any issues,
especially with working with
people who built this campaign
decades ago?
How did you approach teaching
them about the technology and
getting them excited
about that?
Or were they just naturally
gung ho about it?
DREW UNGVARSKY: Because a lot
of them were kind of coming
into it, learning so much new
stuff, they felt like we were
the teachers in that regard.
They were going to teach
us about the brand.
us about their insight.
We were going to show them what
was possible creatively
and technologically today.
I think the push-pull that
happened in the process is
more, again, synonymous of what
happens right now where
you have to try to figure
out what is the right
balance of the idea.
What's the right balance
of the technology?
And show people that, for
example, to tell a story with
just video and just to put a
video in that space doesn't
take advantage of all of the
things that can make it
relevant to its audiences,
that can make people more
likely to engage with it, to
make people stick with it
longer, and so forth.
And so, once people understand,
that's probably
the way to get past
those hurdles.
And we had them, very much so.
There was a constant push-pull,
and I think a
healthy one of creative
and technology input.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And I think that tension
can be very helpful.
In some places, it can
be more difficult.
So it sounds like you guys had
a really good experience with
that, which is awesome.
And, obviously, the output
was amazing.
What was the biggest hangup you
guys came across as you
were trying to put this
thing together?
Be it a technological one or a
cultural issue with the team,
or what was the one thing that
you would say, that was the
real dark night of the soul
for this project?
And how did you get past it?
DREW UNGVARSKY: Oh gosh.
Now, I'm not going to go
too deep into the--
BRIAN MOROZ: You don't
have to name names.
DREW UNGVARSKY: --closet
of skeletons.
There were a lot of
moving parts.
In that campaign, we're looking
at the brand's most
iconic work, work that has
defined that brand, some of
their most famous and
revered advertising.
And we couldn't screw that up.
So we knew right away that was
something not to touch.
Our project was also about
making sure that Google's
technology was used in its most
optimum way, to serve as
an example of how to do
these sort of things.
And so, again, there's trying
to find the right balance of
all those things.
There's individual components
that were--
every project presented
its own hang-ups.
With Alka-Seltzer, we did this
as both a desktop execution
and a mobile execution.
So trying to find a way to do
all of the very dynamic things
that we're doing in desktop, and
do them in mobile without
doubling the work-- a lot of
the stuff that we did in
desktop can't be done in
mobile in the same way.
So thinking about both of those
platforms at the same
time, so we only solve
the problem once.
BRIAN MOROZ: Right.
And I think that's actually a
huge concern for anyone doing
this kind of really, really deep
digital creative work.
I think right now, just across
any platform, is that
connection between desktop
and mobile.
And how do you make that,
exactly like you said, so it's
not double the work?
And I think sometimes it's
almost impossible to do that.
Obviously the technology,
hopefully, is moving in the
direction where it's
easier and easier.
But we've heard that pain point
from everyone in the
past couple days
here, actually.
So I am going to ask you one
final question, and then I'm
going to toss it over to Ryan to
see if he has any questions
for you or if you have
any comments for him.
But if you were going to give
people who want to do
something similar to what you
did, obviously different
ideas, but something in the
direction of the work that you
guys did with Alka-Seltzer,
which has so many moving
pieces, so many API's feeding
into it, so many different
elements, if you had one piece
of advice to give them before
they set out on this
is very large task,
what would that be?
DREW UNGVARSKY: There is a level
of that that the Google
platform is built to do.
The platform is built to know
about its audience.
It's built to know
about location.
There's some very simple signals
that are very easy to
bring into your creative and
very relevant for both
creative and media placement.
And those things, everyone
can and should be doing.
I don't think people are doing
those nearly enough.
If you want to go so far as to
find the limits of those
things, to explore some of the
things that are really finite
details of that, my advice
would be bring a smart
developer in the room and
pair up with Google.
And not just because we worked
with them on the
project with you guys--
Project Weave--
we worked with you guys
on a number of
campaigns just for agencies.
And we always find a technical
correspondant to work with and
make sure we're navigating all
those waters properly.
BRIAN MOROZ: And we didn't even
ask him to say that, by
the way, at all.
DREW UNGVARSKY: I wasn't sure
you'd want me to say that.
BRIAN MOROZ: Well, I'm
fine with that.
Our Developer Relations folks
might now be panicking a
little bit.
But yeah, that's a great
piece of advice.
Wherever you can, partner up.
And your point is really well
taken in that there's just a
lot of very simple triggers you
can use in these kinds of
units that, to your point
exactly, don't
get used very often.
And you can do a lot of
very fun, narrative,
engaging stuff with that.
Ryan, any questions or
comments for Drew?
RYAN TETUAN: Actually, sort of
leading off what he just said.
I'm curious, now that creatives
are starting--
and this is sort of
new in my opinion.
I came from a creative agency
four or five years ago, and we
weren't really thinking
about data signals.
We weren't thinking about how
I can tie weather feed API,
which Drew has done really
well in that
example, into the creative.
And I think now with
programmatic buying and the
way the industry's moving, was
it difficult for you guys to
either find those resources
or identify what
triggers you can use?
Can we, as Google and
DoubleClick, be doing a better
job having creatives understand
what opportunities
there is right now with data?
DREW UNGVARSKY: As I'm engaged
in a project right now that
has got some similar ideas--
what can we do, what are the
latest things--
I really have found that a lot
of the documentation and a lot
of the sales materials
are hugely accurate.
Only the very minute
details of some of
the things are missing.
And those things are always
a quick email away.
So no, I think people have the
tools that they need to do
this kind of stuff.
RYAN TETUAN: Yeah, cool.
I think it's just you guys, and
other creative agencies,
leveraging it and having these
examples to share where are
other great things, as you
start to understand them.
[INAUDIBLE]
DREW UNGVARSKY: And to your
point, how and where to
introduce it into the
conversation?
Where in the process
does it come up?
If you look at Alka-Seltzer, the
whole idea was let's use
those signals that are usually
used for very simple things.
We know the weather, and so
we'll serve you a hot coffee
or an iced coffee.
But we could use that for
a creative platform.
So then, all of a sudden, people
who are used to, say,
writing in Alka-Seltzer's
example, a sitcom script need
to understand cues that
are available to them.
And how do you get those in
there in the right place?
And, again, just sort of a
back and forth process.
RYAN TETUAN: Yeah, cool.
If anyone hasn't seen
it, who's watching,
go to Project Re:Brief.
And actually, I've watched the
Alka-Seltzer ad many times.
And Andrew, I just told you,
there's a little segment where
it actually tied into weather
API, pulled my Los Angeles
weather, and brought that
into the ad unit.
And I used to be a developer.
I can see how that's done.
But what was really cool is
it was on the TV set.
And you guys had a little
shimmer effect to it.
So you sort of took it
to the next level.
So I thought, overall, the
project was great.
And thanks for joining us.
I'll pass it back
over to Brian.
DREW UNGVARSKY: Absolutely.
Thank you.
BRIAN MOROZ: Well,
thank you, Drew.
And for those of you, again,
on the Hangout, if you have
questions for Grow and about
this particular unit, you all
go ahead and throw them
on the moderator.
And Drew, if you'll hang out
with us for another couple of
minutes, we'll switch over now
and talk with the fine folks
at Spinnaker.
Everyone still there?
MALE AND FEMALE SPEAKERS:
Yeah.
BRIAN MOROZ: There they are.
All right.
We have a party going on
over across the pond.
So we're going to go ahead, and
we're going to show the
Sky Fall example.
It's super fun.
Let's go ahead and play the
video, and then we'll jump
back to you guys, do a quick
round of intros, and jump to
some questions.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - "JAMES BOND THEME"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Super, super cool stuff.
Looks pretty complicated, so
I've got some questions for
you guys on how that all
actually was done.
Let's start with the same
question that I asked Drew.
So when you got this as a
client, and when you were
thinking, what do we want to do
with this, how in the world
did you come up with
that specific idea?
Because, like I said, it's
a pretty complicated,
interactive, environmental
thing.
It's involving multiple
devices.
It's a game.
It's social.
What was the idea
process like?
Who was involved in that?
And how did you guys
come up with this?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, in terms
of the inspiration for the
actual game, it was actually
two years in the making.
And then one day, me and my
creative partners, we were
talking about certain
aspects of the film.
And one of the important bits
they were documenting was this
motorbike scene that everyone
was really excited about.
And we thought, what can we do
to engage our audience using
this motorbike scene?
Because it would be really cool
to draw out a motor bike
online or on a banner ad.
And from there on, we just
have experimented with
different stuff.
And then we discovered that the
DoubleClick technology,
the Channel Connect, which
you had used before.
And we thought we'd just
experiment with it.
BRIAN MOROZ: So you knew very
early on that you wanted to do
something game-like using
the motorbike scene.
And then you went and explored
the technologies that were
available and found
the one that fit.
Is that accurate?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, that's
accurate to some extent.
With "Skyfall" and Bond, a lot
of the assets, a lot of the
film is kept secret, as
you're probably aware.
And the creative guys had the
challenge of not actually
knowing what was going to be
the concept at the time.
So we had been working on
"Skyfall" for about two years,
so we knew that it was
going to be big.
But the actual masthead, we
didn't actually know until
about a month, six weeks, before
we saw the media plan.
And that's really the timeline
that we were working towards.
So the guys came up with
the creative concepts.
My and Alice's job to sell
it into the client.
And then from that point, it was
really about bringing all
the people to the project
and delivering the game.
MALE SPEAKER: They actually came
up with three concepts.
And this one was, actually,
the craziest one.
And we didn't think it
would actually run.
And when the client chose
it, we said oh shit.
We have to make it.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah, did
I hear that right?
Did you just say you
had four to six
weeks to put that together?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: About
that, yeah.
BRIAN MOROZ: Let's
talk about that.
So we hear about tight
deadlines.
That's part of agency life
is that's just going
to happen to you.
But that seems unbelievable
to me.
So how did you guys pull that
together that quickly?
You mentioned you've
used it before.
Did you guys just have in-house
experience that made
it a lot quicker?
Who all piled on to make
sure that happened?
Can you talk about that
insane deadline?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So it's something that we're
quite used to working in with
film, because often, those
assets don't get signed off
until the very last minute.
So it's something that
we're used to,
although it's painful.
So, yes.
And we did a similar experience
for "Spider-Man"
back in July, which was
a swipe shooter game.
So we kind of had an idea
of the technology.
But we knew that the Bond, we
wanted to make it slicker and
more exciting, really engage the
young audience, which is
something that Sony were
really keen to do.
And so, once the concept was
signed off and we all caught
our breath, we got Koko
involved, because they have
the gaming knowledge, which
we don't have in house.
And we knew we were going to
need to work [INAUDIBLE]
to make it all come together
so quickly.
So that's where [INAUDIBLE] and
his team were involved. .
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so from our
side of things, the usual
deadline for most games
tends to be around
about four to six weeks.
And to be truthful, this game
engine that they proposed to
us, it's something that we'd
kind of done before in a
previous advert game
that we'd created.
So that was all pretty cool.
Obviously, the main aspect and
the main complication that
really pushed the boundary
out was the dual screen
technology, the fact that you
could actually use the mobile
phone as the controller, and
obviously the fact that its
actually being played inside
a YouTube masthead.
So with that together, that
really did kind of push the
[INAUDIBLE].
It obviously--
whereas we're used to tight
deadlines, like four to six
weeks, that additional aspect,
it was quite a tricky and
quite a daunting task
to begin with.
But it all came together.
And I think, by having the
experience in the game engine
that we'd already created in the
past certainly helped us
to actually overcome the initial
problems that we
[INAUDIBLE] faced with
the controller.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK, yeah.
And that's absolutely fantastic,
the fact that you
can use the phone
to play with it.
I hope that you guys had a lot
of internal experimentation as
you were building it and
had some fun with that.
It's just a really, really
cool use of the device.
To what we were saying earlier,
it's very important
in a lot of cases to have
something that's both desktop
and mobile.
This is a really unique way to
combine those, literally, at
the same time.
Super cool.
Let me ask this, just to go
around the table and all that,
who was the team
that was on it?
What kind of roles
were the people--
because this was such
a unique project.
What kind of people
were pulled in in
order to work on this?
What types of roles?
MALE SPEAKER: So I'm the
innovations planner, and my
role really is to make sure that
I'm pushing the client in
the right direction in digital
and innovation.
So with Alice and the creative
guys, we work as a team to try
and sell the creative
vision and concept
into the client now.
As you see, with something like
this, it takes a leap of
faith for the client
to do this.
Now luckily, we've mentioned
that we did this for
"Spider-Man."
So we have a very fortunate
sector and industry we work in
within film, where they're able
to make those kind of
leaps of faith.
Also, with "Skyfall" being such
a high profile film and
franchise, and the whole 50th
anniversary thing, the idea
that we had to come up with had
to be completely slick and
on brand with "Skyfall."
So Jon and Chris are
the creative team.
They've been working on Sony
for about eight years.
Alice has also been working on
Sony for quite some time.
So we all know Sony
quite well.
So as a project team, we're
quite used to Sony.
People like [INAUDIBLE] and
Koko, they're gaming experts.
And we knew straightaway that we
needed somebody to deliver
that gamification, because we
don't have that in house.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so from our
team, we actually helped
with this development
side of things.
So we have a group
of developers in
house that we utilize.
We also helped with
some of the actual
animation side of things.
While Spinnaker were
responsible, primarily, for
the project planning and the
creative, we were responsible
more for the actual
developments
and the actual campaign.
So yeah.
BRIAN MOROZ: So a lot of
experienced folks in the room,
it sounds like.
It sounds like everyone really
knew what they were doing, has
a history with doing stuff
like this in their own
individual role.
So I imagine that had
to help a lot.
So, interesting team and
interesting project.
And I'm going to ask you the
same question that I asked
Drew, which is, what was the
one biggest issue you guys
ended up confronting?
Be it something with the client,
be it a technical
issue, or team concern, what
was the one thing that made
you all very nervous that
you came through on?
And how did you do it?
MALE SPEAKER: File size.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
I think [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, we got together
with the guys at
DoubleClick very early on.
And when we presented
the [INAUDIBLE]
they said, I doubt that you're
going to be able to do this
within the file size.
And so we went back to the
drawing board, and we
contemplated doing a 2D version,
kind of a bird's-eye
view type version.
But no one had wanted
to let it go.
And so we pushed on.
And thanks to the amazing work
that Koko did, we were able to
make an amazing game but within
file size, which I
think [INAUDIBLE] happy with.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm not
going to deny it.
It certainly was a very
big challenge.
Most of our games tend
to come around about
three to four megs.
So to try and get a game at
this size with the kind of
innovation that was involved,
around the one and a half meg
file size, was certainly
a challenge.
And especially because it needed
to look really slick.
I mean, at the end of the
day, it was James Bond.
So we had to make sure that we
retained that slickness that
you'd expect from a
James Bond game.
And trying to get that
underneath the file size and
make the game actually
playable,
yeah, it was a challenge.
But it was one that we managed
to overcome through quite
careful planning.
It wasn't without its pitfalls,
as we were quite
over towards the end.
But we managed to get it under
a knee in the end outcome.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
So I'm going to actually
pass it over to Ryan.
Ryan, any questions for these
guys on this execution?
RYAN TETUAN: Yeah,
I'm just curious.
I feel like QR codes have been
given somewhat of a bad rep in
the industry, potentially
because people have been,
honestly, using them
incorrectly-- or at least in
marketing incorrectly.
So I'm wondering, when
you brought this--
I guess the initial one was for
"Spider-Man"-- when you
brought it to Sony, were there
any sort of naysayers in the
room saying, are
you guys crazy?
Who scans a QR code?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes, they
were, in fact.
As a creative team, we'd
been trying to get
QR codes into anything.
I mean, we'll try anything,
really.
But I think this was the very
first time we felt quite
strongly that it worked
quite well.
It wasn't redundant.
Most QR codes are redundant.
We just use them in the
Tube, and there's no
reception in the Tube.
And we felt that, for the very
first time, we could actually
use it as a means to connect the
phone, because there was
no other way.
And it could be a quite easy,
simple, and intuitive role in
getting people to punch in a
very long URL, which we do
offer the opportunity for people
to do that if they
[INAUDIBLE] tapping
out a long URL.
But on top of that as well, I
think we were quite familiar
with a quite youthful
audience.
They know what a QR code is.
They know how to react to it.
They're quite familiar with
that language, so they can
just [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: I think it's
also about reducing the
barriers to entry to getting
people to the game as quickly
as possible.
And QR codes seemed the most
obvious way to do that.
RYAN TETUAN: Cool.
And without going into
performance, because that's
proprietary of Sony and
[INAUDIBLE], but would you say
you had what you expected in
terms of game plays, or at
least engagements in the QR
code, or more or less?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I'd say
we've been definitely happy
with the results of the
placement avenue we've had
with the game plays and then
people who went back to play
again and again and again.
So, yeah, everyone
was definitely
happy with the results.
RYAN TETUAN: Cool.
MALE SPEAKER: I know James
Bond was happy.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN TETUAN: Cool.
That's all I had.
I'm pretty sure we have you
guys' "Spider-Man" example in
our Rich Media gallery.
Richmediagallery.com, I'm going
to try my own lower
third right here and
see if this works.
BRIAN: This is how we
roll at Google.
We're very high tech.
RYAN TETUAN: Yeah, I don't think
you can click on it.
It's not that interactive.
But regardless, there's other
Channel Connect examples in
there, so check them
out, everybody.
Good stuff.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right, so I'll
wrap up with you guys
before we see if there
are questions.
Again, it's the same question
that I asked Drew, which is,
given all that you learned from
this very complex, very
short time frame, kind
of intense and
high-profile campaign.
If someone was trying to do
something similar-- they
wanted to do gamification,
they wanted to use mobile
phones, something in the general
direction that you
guys pioneered here--
what would be your one piece
of advice to them?
MALE SPEAKER: I would say get
the technology working first
before you start applying the
creative look and feel.
And also partner up--
as mentioned on the previous
call-- but partner up
extremely quickly with
DoubleClick and Google, and
open all communication
channels.
Make sure everybody knows what
you're trying to achieve and
what the output is and what
the [INAUDIBLE] is.
MALE SPEAKER: And what
the deadline is.
MALE SPEAKER: And basically,
don't give up.
Just if you think it's going
to work in your mind, just
push for it.
BRIAN MOROZ: Push through.
Know your technology
first, though.
Good pieces of advice.
All right, so we just have a
couple of questions from the
folks that are listening in.
And the first is-- and we can
ask actually both groups here.
And Drew, are you still
hanging out with us?
DREW UNGVARSKY: Still here.
BRIAN MOROZ: Excellent.
So we'll start with you, and
then we'll jump over to our
Spinnaker friends.
But the question first, from
Dave in London, is what were
the metrics?
Were you guys looking at clicks,
hits, engagement?
Because these units are very
different from your standard
display ad unit, what was
actually being measured?
What meant success?
DREW UNGVARSKY: Yeah, that's a
weird question to answer for
this because ours was an
experiment to show
advertisers.
The ads didn't actually
run in media.
They ran for Google.
The metric, though, is whether
we could get people to engage,
whether we could capture all
of the functionalities that
are available to us, and do so
in a way that re-imagined that
ad and did it justice.
Again, with advertising at that
level, we were going to
be scrutinized very,
very heavily.
So if we put too much technology
into it or didn't
really push the idea to a new
place, then we were certainly
going to be scrutinized.
BRIAN MOROZ: Gotcha.
And for "Skyfall," you mentioned
people coming back
to the game again and again,
posting their scores.
What were you guys looking
for as saying this was a
successful engagement
with this unit?
MALE SPEAKER: So it's really how
long you spend on the page
and the duration.
Also, we had some social
elements to that, so it's
about sharing and getting
everyone to come not only to
the masthead but to
keep them there.
So that was really
our main KPI.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
And that's an interesting use
of those types of ads units
and I think a really exciting
way to do that, rather than a
simple, we just want
to accumulate the
maximum number of clicks.
Very different way of measuring
and looking at, how
are people engaging with this?
So our second question-- and
we'll still hang out with you
guys, Spinnaker, and
then we'll flip
back to Drew at Grow--
is what is your advice for
balancing the client and the
creative and using DoubleClick
Rich Media specifically?
So how do you balance
those two things?
That's from Jill in Denver.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're very
fortunate that our client also
really wants to push
the new technology.
So we often, when we know we've
got a particular film
coming out, we'll go in and
speak to people at DoubleClick
early, before we even know what
sort of media plan so we
can look at what new ideas are
out there, work with them, put
those ideas foward
to the client.
But yeah, we're lucky that he's
as [INAUDIBLE] as we are
in terms of new digital
technology.
MALE SPEAKER: I think also, just
to add to that, it's got
to be relevant within
the film market.
It's got to be relevant
to the film.
So something like the YouTube
masthead DoubleClick Channel
Connect technology, "Skyfall"
is perfect for that.
So it's about getting
the balance right.
BRIAN MOROZ: Gotcha.
DREW UNGVARSKY: And on our end,
I would just say make
sure your client is aware of
what the real opportunity is.
If you look at this as a resize
of a website, if you
look at it as a resize of a
print ad, then you're not
doing with the media what
it's capable of doing.
And you won't see any of the
types of things that you
really expect to
get out of it.
But if know what those things
are, if you know that this is
a channel that does things that
no other channel does,
you can create creative for
that and see it perform
remarkably well.
BRIAN MOROZ: That's
a great point.
So we will end on that.
And I want to say a huge thanks
to Drew over at Grow
and to all of our friends over
Spinnaker for joining us.
You can see their work at
www.creativesandbox.com, and
we recommend that you guys go
there and check out some of
these amazing DoubleClick units
and the things that
they've done.
They go way beyond a
unit in that term.
They're full-blown experiences,
so please go
check them out.
And for those of you that will
join us tomorrow, same time,
same channel.
We'll be talking about
Google+ API.
So hopefully I will
see you there.
And thanks so much to both
agencies for coming on board
and chatting with us.
And have a great afternoon.